Alright, in this module we're going to talk about how we can also connect devices together
by using wireless technologies, but alright, in this module we're going to talk about how
we can also connect devices together by using wireless technologies, but one of the things
that we have to think about in anything wireless is that we can't really control how we
connect devices together because by definition wireless signals will span outwards in all directions
and so that makes it particularly challenging to protect anything that is wireless and
you know up until a number of years ago this was something that companies resisted simply
because it was so hard to protect wireless communications, but nowadays we can protect
wireless really well by using some of the technologies and protocols that are available
that we're going to talk about here, but first of all you know the fundamental problem
of wireless and how it reaches out in all directions is something that companies need to think
about certainly from a architecture perspective, so if you look at the slide that's in front
of you right here, it really depicts what a typical architecture may look like, very
simplified of course, but what a typical architecture may look like in any organization
where you know organizations have their own internal network that is connected to the
internet so that we can take advantage of the opportunities that the web and the internet
offers us to be able to keep our clients and customers happy, but we may also have what
are called a DMZ which is a sub network where we're going to put services that may be required
from the outside internet, that means people that are trying to order our products and
interface with us in a nice easy way requires us to have applications that we're going to
put in the DMZ as opposed to letting them come in to the internal network and so that's
where we're going to put things related to any service that is required from the outside
internet, but if you think about wireless this is also where we want to put our Wi-Fi capabilities
because then anybody connecting to those Wi-Fi access points, if they want to be able
to get into the internal network we'll still have to go through the firewall which is there
to provide security so that we only allow what should be allowed in the internal network so
that ultimately we are protecting the value of those assets and services that are ultimately
inside of our network, so if you look at the architecture that is depicted here that is a
good one from a security perspective because anybody connecting to that would have to go through
the firewall to be able to access anything of value in the internal network, now you could
have a guest Wi-Fi so this is a typical architecture that a lot of organizations have, this is where
you would place your Wi-Fi capabilities that you offer guests which could be on the outside
and not in any way connected to the internal network which again is the most important thing
to protect, the value of the internal network and its services is what we want to ultimately protect,
so your guest Wi-Fi capabilities are going to be outside of the firewall, now you could also have
what most companies do and that is a corporate Wi-Fi that only authorized individuals are allowed
to connect to, and this is where you would have really good security to force, not only authentication
but probably two factor authentication for anyone that may be a employee of the organization
to connect to that type of network, now one of the other things that we have to think about
from a wireless perspective is what we call radio frequency management and what this means is that
the placement of certain wireless access points need to be done securely and what you depict here,
what you see here is not very secure because we've placed a wireless access point in the corner
of a building where the signals will span outwards towards locations and areas that you cannot control,
for example your parking lot or other buildings that may be next to you, so a better architecture
would be the place that wireless access point in the middle of the building so that you can limit
the signals and what they can reach to areas that you don't trust, now understanding something called
the radio frequency spectrum allows us to understand why it's important for us to protect certain
types of traffic that operate at frequencies within this wireless radio spectrum, so the ones that
you see in yellow there, 802.11, B and G, Bluetooth and some wireless phones, but also the 802.11,
AN and AC represent what are called the frequencies that are established as being unlicensed,
so the yellow frequencies that you see there, 2.4 gigahertz and 5 gigahertz and I think there's
actually another one that we don't see there that has been recently established as being also
unlicensed in the 60 range are what we call unlicensed radio frequencies and what that means
is that anyone because it's unlicensed that means any vendor for example can create a technology
that operates within those frequencies, but from a security perspective that's a problem isn't it
because if you have a whole bunch of things that people can create technologies that can operate
within those radio frequencies that may contend with what we're trying to do as an organization
or they those devices that others create that operate within those radio frequencies
may also be able to pick up the signals that are operating within those frequencies and so the
problem is when you look at this entire radio frequency band there is really no security built in
I mean the radio frequency band does not have any security built in therefore we need to add security
if we want security of wireless and here are examples I mean Wi-Fi is the most obvious example
of where we use radio frequencies that are wireless that do not have any security built in
but it also includes other technologies like Bluetooth and cellular and RFID but the
bottom line is that each of these technologies all have the same problems and that is there is
no security built in to anything that you're using to connect wirelessly or to communicate wirelessly
so what you want to remember from this slide especially specifically is that if you want security
to exist of anything that is wireless there are really four things that you need to address
there are four security services that need to be addressed in anything that is wireless
and it is what you see on the left hand side of this table right if you want security of wireless
you need to address access control you need to address authentication you need to address encryption
and you need to address integrity protection and what you see here is what the industry has come
up with in order to address those things for anything that's wireless and so if you look at 802.1x
the four methods that are used for addressing access control authentication encryption
and integrity is what we've provided in that table so 802.1x for example uses 802.1x for
access control it uses EAP methods to authenticate individuals it uses web for encryption which you
know is not something that is very secure any longer and it uses nothing for integrity protection
and that's why what you see in this table is more relevant and that is what's better to protect
anything wireless is WPA and WPA2 and most organizations today have standardized on WPA2
capabilities to protect anything that's wireless and when you look at the specific methods that
this chart provides for each of the requirements being access control authentication encryption
and integrity protection WPA2 uses a pre-shared key for both access control and authentication
it uses something called CCMP which is really the AES algorithm which you know of used in counter
mode for encryption and for integrity protection it also uses something called CCMP which is really
a message authentication code that is encrypted in CBC mode of the AES algorithm and you'll
know probably that you know companies there are two different ways to use WPA2 personal mode
and enterprise mode and most companies will standardize on enterprise mode which may require
people to two factor authenticate and possibly provide some other information before you can
actually connect to that corporate Wi-Fi that is using WPA2 so that's definitely the best method
to protect anything wireless and we're achieving the four requirements of protecting anything wireless
which as you can see here is access control authentication encryption and integrity protection
now this is a summary of what we've just talked about because the exam may ask you to understand
what are the four security services that must always be addressed if you want to protect
anything wireless and so you'll know that it is access control authentication encryption
and integrity protection you may have to memorize those although I think it's pretty intuitive
now in anything that relates to authentication these are some of the methods that are typically
used for that that's why WPA2 is the best method to achieve authentication because it can force
two factor authentication that may use as we just saw EAP methods for that and one of the important
things that you see at the bottom of this slide is that in typical connections related to wireless
you want to achieve what's called mutual authentication that means that both parties connecting to
each other wirelessly need to authenticate to each other so authentication has to happen both
ways in order for us to trust and then of course anything that we send back and forth would require
encryption integrity protection and the other services that we just saw as part of that slide
and for wireless encryption most of the methods will use AES which is by far the best algorithm
that we've seen in the cryptography domain as part of this presentation but WPA2 uses as you can
see here CCMP which is the AES used in counter mode which is the best mode to encrypt and at least
with 128 bit keys is pretty standard now for integrity protection TKIP we're going to talk about
coming up because TKIP was actually developed to replace WEP which we know is flawed and vulnerable
so TKIP was really the first attempt to come up with something that could replace WEP because by
that point every organization out there that was offering wireless was using WEP and as soon as
we found that WEP was flawed and vulnerable the industry had to move very quickly to come up with
something like a band-aid solution to really address the vulnerabilities that WEP had what they
came up with very quickly is something called TKIP and so TKIP was an attempt to try and fix
the vulnerabilities that WEP had and by today's standards it's no longer good to use TKIP methods
for integrity protection and encryption and in fact WPA2 uses something called CCMP as well that
we outlined earlier before which is really a message authentication code that is protected by using
the AES algorithm used in CBC mode and in fact here is 802.1X which is really one of the earliest
ways to achieve security for wireless and it did use something called TKIP. Here's some information
on TKIP because we have heard from some people that there may be still some questions on the exam
that relate to TKIP so this provides a summary of TKIP actually was in order to address the problems
that we had identified in the industry related to WEP. WEP is flawed and vulnerable one of the best
ways or one of the quickest ways that the industry came up to address the problems related with WEP
was to implement TKIP which was developed to replace WEP and address the vulnerabilities of it
but as you can see with the bottom statement that we have there TKIP is no longer considered to be
secure and is superseded by using AES methods that are really included within WPA2. The best method to
protect wireless today is definitely WPA2 used in wireless or in enterprise mode.